حسنًا ، اعتقدت أننا كنا في المرتبة
الثانية بعد فريق جيد جدًا ،
ومن الواضح أننا لسنا في لحظة
رائعة بأنفسنا ، وعلى الرغم من أنها كانت في
قفص في أول 20 دقيقة ،
لم نتمكن من الهجوم  خط الخفافيش
جيدًا بما فيه الكفاية ، لم نتمكن من الهجوم
كما نرغب في
فعل مانشستر سيتي
بشكل جيد حقًا من حيث منعك من القيام بذلك
ولكن في نفس الوقت عانينا من أجل
أنه هدف أول رائع من
حيث  تسديدة من ركلة حرة مباشرة وضربة
جزاء غريبة ثم يتم القبض عليه في
موقف حيث لا
شيء وعليك أن تطارد الكرة ضد
مانشستر سيتي وتعلق بين
محاولة إلحاق المزيد من الرجال وعدم
الانفتاح ،
لذا في الشوط الأول  كان مؤلمًا وكان الأمر
صعبًا بالنسبة لنا جميعًا في
الشوط الثاني ، كان علينا الرد ، اعتقدت أن
هناك بعض الإيجابيات هناك
من حيث اللاعبين الشباب الذين اعتقدت
أنهم قدموا كل شيء وأظهروا
جودتهم ولكن في النهاية شعرنا
بخيبة أمل  لأننا خرجنا  في
المنافسة ، تهانينا لمانشستر
سيتي الذين يستحقون الفوز بالطبع
ونحن نشعر بخيبة أمل
لأننا خرجنا